wenn ihr ein hochbeet habt euer eigenes
runterladen dass ich so ein pdf und da
ab mai ungefähr mit einer organischen
befüllt darauf wo das denn wirklich hin
gemüse anbauen wollt dann gibt es dabei
in der herstellung gerade wenn es auch
und soll das jetzt voll pflanzen und da
ist sie sächsischen ausgeklügelt wie man
schicht ab also nicht die gemüsepflanzen
soll es ist sehr gut wenn euer hochbeet
einiges zu beachten und auch einiges was
fangen wir mal mit dem ersten fehler an
nur wenn das konventionelle freue ist
man falsch machen kann und damit euch
bedenken sondern den boden um die
schaut mal wo in ihrem garten süden ist
da steht wo am meisten sonne es ist auch
die juso wird pflanzt man rund ums jahr
das nicht passiert kommen hier die
aber die meisten pferde kriegen ja kein
pflanzen dafür kann man heute abschnitt
häufigsten fehler und wie sie vermeidet
bio ei sondern konventionell angebaute
ernten kann dass alle gemüse auch
sehr gut wenn es möglichst nah am haus
damit die pflanzen die richtig hoch
viel spaß ihr habt ja so ein hochbeet
zu nehmen oder rasenschnitt alles was im
treu da werden pflanzenschutzmittel
zueinander passen es gibt gewisse die
steht damit ihr auch mitbekommt wenn da
wachsen auch auf die nordseite des
mögen sich die unterstützen sich die
zum beispiel schädlinge unterwegs sind
garten alles möglich beteiligt auf
eingesetzt die auch gegen gemüse wirken
hofgutes gibt's sonst werden weil die
sich auch krankheiten und schädlinge vom
also überlegt euch gut wo das geht hin
meinen beten um den boden zu bedecken
und die sind dann nachher natürlich auch
leib aber es gibt auch gemüse die können
den anderen pflanzen sonst super
und vor verdunstung zu schützen weil man
schatten machen so dass erst mal drauf
soll und befüllt es erst danach weil
sich überhaupt nicht leiden und
im heu und die wirken zum beispiel gegen
unterdrückt die sich gegenseitig im
so viel viel viel weniger gießen muss
wenn es einmal befüllt ist dann könnt
wachstum oder übertragen sich gegenseite
achten wenn wir planen wollt was da rein
darüber kann ich euch auch noch mal ein
pflanzenfamilien unter den beiden
krankheiten das will man natürlich
ihr das nicht mehr verrückt und dann
videofilm wenn ihr lust habt zu lernen
kräutern wo auch die kreuzblütler zu
gepflanzt werden soll dass die höheren
steht es da und dann bleibt es da und es
vermeiden man will auch eine fruchtfolge
wie man weniger gießen muss dann
pflanzen wie zum beispiel tomaten jetzt
gehören das sind die kohlgemüse das ist
wird natürlich doof wenn das dann dover
schreibt es noch in die video
einhalten so dass man nicht jedes jahr
nicht unbedingt an der südseite eures
beschreibung aber dass es in hochbeeten
standort wäre ich kann euch hier nochmal
zum beispiel der kohlrabi der weißkohl
das gleiche gemüse im beet anbaut und
pcs wachsen weil das wäre gar keine gute
so ein paar kriterien einblenden die ich
eben viel viel wichtiger und den
das ist der blumenkohl der rotkohl der
deswegen ladet euch gerne meinen
idee und so richtig hohe pflanzen würde
beachten würde wenn ich überlege wo der
hochbeeten ist auch total wichtig dass
pflanzplan runter der es hier oben
vilsinger also eine ganze menge von
beste ort was wir um den hof aufzubauen
ich auch grundsätzlich nicht unbedingt
man regelmäßig gießt das mache ich ihnen
verlinkt und unten in der video
gemüsen auch die radieschen würden dann
in den opel tanzten es kommt immer so
und dann glauben auch viele leute das
beschreibung und dann könnt ihr das
im ebenerdigen beten nicht denn die
nicht mehr gut wachsen in so einer erde
schmecken nicht in hochbeete kommen weil
einfach so in ihrem garten umsetzen ohne
ein bisschen drauf anrufe bitte können
pflanzen gesät wurden dann natürlich
sie ja so ewig langen hoch kriechen
wo dieses zeug drin ist und die wirken
ja so hoch sein oder sie können so hoch
euch vor den kopf zu zerbrechen wenn ihr
schon da muss der boden feucht bleiben
müssen bis sie dann irgendwann an das
aber im sommer müssen sie dann lernen
auch gegen regellosen leguminosen sind
sein und wenn ihr so ist hochbeet hart
nur ein beat habt dann sucht euch
gemüse kommen aber pustekuchen
selber grad zu kommen und das klappt in
einfach das aus dass am leckersten
erbsen und bohnen ist natürlich auch
die sind viel hartnäckiger als man
und eine tomate rein pflanzt die ja auch
hochbeeten aber nicht und deswegen würde
aussieht und nehmt das und wechselt dann
total schade wenn man die dann nicht
manchmal glaubt und die kommen auch in
mehr anfangen kann oder die einfach
ich euch auch raten wenn es dann einmal
noch mal zwei meter hoch wird dann kommt
jahr für jahr einfach immer so weiter
nicht mehr so gut wachsen weil man
hochbeeten reihen deswegen müssen wir da
pro woche aber richtig gut so dass der
er natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr an
pferdemist verwendet hat wo das zeug
durch das ihr jedes jahr oder andere
gut drauf aufpassen man kann wenn man
eure ernten tragen dann ist die auch den
boden richtig durchfeuchtet wird weil
pflanze auf eurem bieten hat dass es
nur ein paar hochbeete hat im garten und
eventuell drin das ist natürlich eine
wind viel zu sehr ausgesetzt
soll noch mal im transplantat lehrt also
wenn ihr ein bisschen gut man mit
sache das muss jeder für sich selber
überhaupt keine lust sich mit den
ja die sowieso wahrscheinlich irgendwann
entscheiden vielleicht kann man ja auch
holt euch gehen gerne und dann würde ich
schnecken schnecken herumzuplagen dann
nachfragen was das pulver das gespritzt
pflanzen unter jeden tag mit der
abbrechen wird oder sich hin und her
kann man um das hochbeet drumherum ein
gerne noch mal einen trick beraten und
gießkanne vorbeikommt dann werden die
wurde oder nicht von der saison nicht so
schneckenzaun sozusagen an dem hochbeet
biegt deswegen achtet mal so ein
dass alle spritzen mittel gegen diese
natürlich abhängig davon dass wir jeden
bisschen darauf wie groß werden denn die
zwar geht es richtig coole ton tegel die
anbringen das funktioniert sehr gut
gemüsepflanzen möchte und wie hoch sind
pflanzen familien wirken bilden würde
tag kommt deswegen es ist viel schlauer
kann man einfach in die lern stecken und
gemacht das anders ich schützt die
diese gemüse irgendwie unterdrücken
die dann irgendwann also stangenbohnen
wenn man ihnen wurden einmal richtig gut
zwar am besten zwischen die pflanzen
pflanzen einzelnen auch mit einem
würden aber die frage spielt natürlich
sind zum beispiel keine guten kandidaten
durchfeuchtet einmal pro woche so dass
dann kann man einfach eine alte
schneckenzaun aber deswegen anders aus
und weil das ziemlich ärgerlich ist
sind hoch bild dann würde ich eher
die pflanzen überall wasser haben auch
weinflaschen nehmen da wasser einfüllen
schnecken kragen heißen die das sind so
busspuren zu lanz nur in ihrem boden so
in tieferen bodenschichten dann
versuche ich kein pferdemist in meinem
hüte gibt's aus plastik oder auch aus
die umgekehrt in den tunnel stecken dann
gerne mild das funktioniert auch sehr
verdunstet das auch weniger stellen und
garten zu verwenden dazu kommt auch noch
kann man auch mal in urlaub fahren weil
sehr gut die sind auch super ertragreich
nicht so abhängig davon sind dass ihr
metall und damit kann man die gemüse
dass pferdemist ja oft auch unkrautsamen
dann nach und nach das wasser an die
jeden tag einfach nur ein bisschen
aber ihr kommt eben auch noch dran
wasser hat denn entwickeln die ihre
pflanzen abgeben wird und so müsst ihr
sehr gut schützen dem ist natürlich auch
enthält so dass man nicht mehr
bei tomaten gibt es auch so die das
wurzeln auch nur an der bodenoberfläche
für beachten in meinen hochbeeten sind
unkrautfrei gärtnern kann so haben wir
weil sie wissen dass da immer das wasser
nicht mehr so viel dies mit euren
dafür hochbeete geeignet sind zum
vielmehr für wir unterwegs als wir den
kommt dass sie gar nicht tiefer wurzeln
auch schon mal ein video gemacht das war
hochbeeten und das ist richtig
beispiel balkon tomaten oder auch bush
müssen und so könnt ihr eure pflanzen
ebenerdigen bieten und wenn es richtig
den ich gerne da oben und weil das
praktischer tipp der auch super offenbar
auch in hochbeeten schon so ein bisschen
tomaten die kann man dann auch über die
funktioniert ich kann euch die tonlage
schlimm wird dann einfach drüber machen
wirklich super praktisch ist wenn man
darauf erziehen dass sie ein bisschen
wände des hochwertigsten bisschen grund
unabhängiger werden kann geld in
die beete so anlegt das dann darin kein
um die abzuhalten wie möglich zu
auch gerne und in der video beschreibung
ranken lassen und das funktioniert dann
hochbeeten genauso wie in anderen bieten
verlinken noch ein tipp denkt daran dass
unkraut wächst also wenn ihr das video
verhindern dass sie etwas nach und nach
auf jeden fall um einiges besser wenn
was man oft unterschätzt wie groß die
noch nicht gesehen habt dann schaut euch
ihr ein früher kit kasten auf eure
ihr den niedriges hochbeet habt was
die schon hoch betreibt und kennt ihr
das auf jeden fall an das ist auch für
gemüsepflanzen später werden gerade so 1
hochbeete darauf montieren können das
vielleicht nur so knie hoch ist dann
das dass das hochbeet immer weiter
hochbeete wichtig und das pack ich euch
braucht ihr euch darüber überhaupt keine
kohl plätzchen das ist ja am anfang nur
ist einfach in den kasten der so fenster
nochmal in die video beschreibung dann
sorgen zu machen dann könnt ihr alles
absackt und irgendwann können die
so groß und das wird aber so ein okay
hat ich habe auch welche ja auch meinen
habt ihr wenn ihr meinen kanal schon
pflanzen was ihr denkt auch daran wenn
pflanzen nicht mal mehr über den hoch
wenn man das lässt und über will ja auch
ihr gerade in ein hochbeet gebaut habe
länger kennt ja wahrscheinlich schon
hochbeeten und so kann man im winter
bildrand rausschauen das ist natürlich
clique kohlköpfe irgendwann deswegen
gehört dass ich versuche möglichst wenig
übrigens ich filme gerade ein hochbeet
durch pflanzen photosynthese machen wir
noch viel mehr gemüse anbauen und auch
achtet wenn ihr das hochbeet pflanzt auf
zu gießen in meinem garten und das
bauen video also wenn ihr noch mehr
müssen an die sonne kommen und deswegen
im frühling viel früher ernten und auch
jeden fall immer darauf wie viel platz
klappt auch sehr sehr gut aber nicht in
hochbeete wollt oder doch was haben denn
denkt daran dass wenn das wintergemüse
viel frühjahr pflanzen man kann im herz
die einzelnen gemüse dann überhaupt
der den kanal abonnieren da kommt doch
meinen hochbeeten das liegt daran ist
brauchen und bevor ihr pflanzt müsst ihr
aktivsten bevor er das frühlingsgemüse
die pflanzen davor schützen dass sie
einfach darüber wie man das hochbeet
die hochbeete ja überirdisch wenn die
pflanzt dass ihr eure hochbeete dann
auf jeden fall auch noch auf flügeln
erfrieren und noch länger sozusagen in
dann gefüllt und sowieso klar nicht ganz
sind ja höher gelegt und dadurch kann
einmal richtig schön auf schild mit
welches gemüse denn
das wasser das in den genen enthalten
viele hochbeet videos also gerne
den winter hinein ernten im sommer
neuer erde so dass die pflanzen auch
wohin wandern soll das ist auch gar
abonnieren und auch die glocke
ist das sei und pflanzen sie eigentlich
natürlich den appell so ungefähr mai
zur verfügung stehen sollte aber auch
wieder auf dem gleichen niveau sind wie
nicht so einfach so einen anbau plan zu
aktivieren damit ihr dann bescheid
kommt ja von meinen bilden runter kommt
im letzten jahr ein großer fehler und
viel leichter verdunsten und deswegen
bekommt wenn die videos da sind aber
erstellen dazu habe ich auch ganz viele
das ist jetzt ein bisschen kontrovers
in den keller und dann schrauben so im
woran wir genau handy ein hoch gebaut
videos hier auf dem kanal die euch gerne
ist pferdemist zu verwenden oder
ist es umso wichtiger dass man hochbeete
oktober wieder dran und dass es auf
anschauen könnte ich auch gerne der
und ihr wollt das in euren garten
verorteten pferdemist kompost aus
muss ich denke immer alle meine bilder
stellen dann achtet bevor ihr das
linke es gibt aber auch einen
jeden fall eine riesengroße bereicherung
pferdemist das machen ja viele leute im
einfacheren weg und zwar habe ich einen
gerade wenn man auch keinen gewächshaus
garten aber ich bin da ehrlich gesagt
hat der frühere kasten ist bei mir
pflanzplan hier könnt ihr euch einfach
gar keine unser freund von weil
genauso cool wie das gewächshaus ist
natürlich kleiner aber das ist eine
super super sache um viel vielfältiger
auch in den kalten jahreszeiten zu
ernten wenn ihr euch jetzt noch fragt ja
aber so ungemein über das gemüse
gärtnern da war ich ja noch gar nichts
da schaut gerne da trieben vorbei da
verlinkt ich euch nur nämlich mein
gemüse anbauen anfänger video wo ja alle
tricks bekommt damit die razzien und
loslegen könnt und dann macht das auch
schnappt euch auch ein gummistiefel und
geht raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video ts
macht's gut